the patriots had the same helmet for the
last 30 years but the uniform has
changed multiple times and now
they have new uniforms chris sims they
have taken their color rush uniform and
made it their home uniform blue on blue
with the red and white stripes over the
tops of the shoulders they have
fashioned a new road jersey that will go
along with the blue pants very simple
very kind of a classic but modern feel
at the same time and strange to see it
because usually it's the teams that
can't get out of their own way that have
to generate some offseason buzz with a
new uniform but with tom brady moving on
i guess the patriots felt compelled to
do something to get somebody to buy
jerseys that don't say brady on the back
see if you change the jerseys there's no
reason to buy any more brady jerseys
they're probably going to get sick of
seeing brady jerseys but i bet there'll
be some boston fans that buy the new
road jersey with 12 and brady on the
back
without a doubt i mean yes you can make
up your own jersey as you buy these
things like on nfl.com and all that so
you're right you're going to see that i
like the look i do you know it's not a
big change but like you said it's kind
of like some classic red redesign there
i like the stripes on the pants i'm a
big fan of their color rush all blue
uniform you know what's interesting to
me mike i mean are they going to phase
out the silver pants because you know we
did see silver pants a lot of the times
on the road with their white jersey and
stuff like that is that going to be no
longer
those are the photos that we have posted
so i don't know what else is going to be
part of the ensemble most teams like to
have those three different options
the one thing they can't do until they
get rid of the one helmet rule is go
back to pat patriot with the white
helmet but that could be back as soon as
2021 they really need to do that ditch
the one helmet rule so we can bring back
the classic uniforms from time to time
that just generates so much excitement
and anticipation whether it's the
creamsicles the pat patriot the old
oilers uniforms whatever it may be
there's a lot of fun that we could have
with the look and the feel of some of
these uniforms if they would just get
rid of the rule that i still don't
understand why if it's the same model
helmet why you have to have only one all
year long and can't wear a second one
well that i don't understand that either
i mean yeah i mean with modern
technology and all the money the nfl has
we can't figure out a way to get a
second helmet involved in the you know
in the rotation here that i find that
hard to believe too and you're right
again it would just lead to everything
you say and sometimes you complain about
there's another helmet more things to
sell on the market and things like that
another logo another look
i would think the nfl would be all over
that and i would think we could find a
way to have a second helmet and still
have that you know pass all the
specifications for safety as far as the
nfl is concerned
i don't have a problem with new stuff to
buy i object to it when the poor sucker
that just bought the thing with the old
logo yesterday all of a sudden finds out
that it's going to be obsolete next week
when they unveil the new uniform people
should get a little more a little more
advanced notice
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports